HEY how's it going
I'm here today with a special guest... [who is it pewds]
eHHH actually not so special guest
i mean, of cou-- [laughs]
NO WHERE ARE YOU GOING
[♪mUsIc♪]
you need to co- what are you doing
AYEEEEEE [oh hi]
what's goin on
[both] aYeee
[F] ???
youu
OH IT'S PJ
PJ: Hey everybody, what's going on Felix?
how you- you wa- wa
what's going on
[sad music]
Why are we still here...
F: Uhhh, PJ, uh *talking in broken french and weird english*
PJ: YES I am a big speaker of many languages
Is that what dumbass, broken game we're playing today?
F: What do you mean "dumbass broken game"? We got- This is a great game!
PJ: So- Something to do with language maybe?
F: Yes.
PJ: Ok.
F: As you can tell we are...in a different part of the world today.
PJ: WA-AH!   F: Uh-huh-
PJ: Is that the Eiffel tower behind us?
F: Yes. I do believe that is the Eiffel tower.
PJ: Wow, it's so pointy.
F: I've always wanted to go to France.
PJ: Yeah... Me? Not so much.
F: Let's play the language game!
PJ: Let's do it, so hyped.
*epic mlg airhorns*
F: Only I can do it.
This game, there is a ....
You have to guess the language.
PJ: *reads* "The Great Language Game"
F: "The Great Language Game", that's right and there's a reward for winning -
PJ: Is it a fidget spinner?
F: God damn it *laughing*
PJ: Wow... F: You will get to spin the fidget spinner
PJ: I've already got one...so...don't really need that one.
F: Well this one is...
PJ: Masculine.
This one's... much better.
F: Okay, well there's a punishment-
PJ: What?
F: If you lose -
PJ: Is the punishment that I DON'T get the fidget spinner?
F: YES! And...you will get hurt by the fidget spinner.
PJ: Ok.
F: Yeah...and depending how-how many wrong that's how many spins you can charge it up.
PJ: Wow.
F: Got it?
PJ: Ok, yes. One, two, three..
Yeah sounds good let's do it
it all right get all you etre since you
are the guest I'll let you start
all right thanks before that women know
nada
let me hear an Amir ask but I Zeke iliac
really Bruce just William II die are
about Irina
strawberry Middle Ages to love man you
yellow station Roberto basically liberal
at the slower other Posner
okay yeah I hear what you're saying yeah
mmhmm yep
I'm gonna take a wild guess come on I'm
gonna get more that it is Russia dammit
yeah hey 50 points not bad hi I heard
dad died ruble to you was it working in
Russian yeah nice is one of the few
words I know you know better Russian and
know a bit of Russian I'm a man of many
languages just like you said a man of
the world a manner that's what you think
throw in not to convict tomato part of
the intro Allah they will know cut to
them say a part of the yen drone Arabic
LaLaurie and volume very polar William
tear nothing available in Tioga trivial
such an important day in the year and
the previous normal pioneer Khurana
novel yes why is this
well don't worry about the score
it's me versus you one one right
you're going down boy
you're going down
In Spanish - I don't think  anyone will have any doubts
From the credibility of the Seabot figures
In other news
The first minister, Kevin Rudd, deposed as a candidate...
Ok, i'm... i'm hearin' it
I don't hear anything. I have no idea
...accusations of bad behavior which occurred eleven years ago
Lake was forced to apologize again for having.
now what the fuck was that Spanish I've
been to Spain
I've got Spanish friends and they say
remember who a sister knows it a
scannable here early on of all of them
of the famous critical mag i sat and a
mediation people in action guys the fuck
is a terrible a lot that you like you're
offending everyone who live in Telugu
swear in Telugu and my favorite pants in
the Telugu I don't know a relative
activity one year we pull up the doc is
it Haitian
Haitian I think that's how you pronounce
ID from Haiti okay sorry I'm not I'm not
entirely sure of myself but this is your
guy look at this formula movie chemistry
tickle bug I said and then equation
typically Lennox Gardens anions a file
ready okay
Turkish it was Asian
it was Haitian I like you knew that I
like you knew that I may have added
inkling
hello inkling incidentally orange in
Nigeria an important enough major Khmer
Rouge hid
naaku chaala guru buddha dunno Kabuto
Tianjin the Gihon American winger Boko
Haram Jamal a clash Allah meteor come on
what is a house that I know what it's
not hey I'm speaking Howser what's that
Felix seriously there are people
watching this who speak houses fuck you
how then fluently I'm my god come on man
look you saw a girl would go kaput or
the engine the Gihon Oh Maya con el
Cucuy are Boko Haram yeah so much a man
I know what you know it's not Haitian
yes yeah in theory I know it's not
German I don't think it's Korean
yeah fucking housing I don't think it's
Chinese I'm gonna get Howser fucking
how's that
thank you people people who know people
who speak out all over the world this
place is the worst
this is I love this place is my favorite
worst place I've ever been it I'm loving
it here right worse than must be so
score so five like three one no three
two three two okay we try and cheat now
Nigel named Barney Lynn Bonnie coca-cola
but in some good rewrite our new things
learn you be home home funny it was
Chinese woo
what the fuck is the world Caprica you
cheer afirma que le Rouge oficial de
parte aeropuerto de la Sharm el-sheikh
are a difficult urge ku numeral married
a person a car a versa played in Egypt
guys a difficult one because I don't
think it's Italian because there's not
enough kind of like it's definitely not
Italian no matter or is how every
contact here that's what I'm saying
it I don't and it's not enough what by
the Irish it's not going up like Italian
kind of right this is very sentence in
Italian language it's not that muffled
alarm st sorry difficult urge ku numeral
mari de persona Carrie what's up Richard
in Egypt yeah I will go with between
Romanian I notice bang it could be
Romanian could be us back 50 click the
PJ you're scared
yeah oh nice Romanian thank you Michael
Chang space yeah yeah fuck you Michael
United we fake Romanian in work the on a
frog vanity work stencil what the fuck
is an Afrikaans well that's the language
they sound like three well I said you're
a man of the world
I was my misjudged shoes what what about
your amount of sweeter it just seems
kind of weird it's like you come from
Europe and you're like I speak Europe
and my okay whatever Africans Africa
again ah I guess hell yeah I'm balancing
store and emotional state I think I name
is to my booting and you know if they
unify think I know where I became your
brain apart a long quote you I will be
two ton of China love Sicily yeah I
might think come on possibly yeah god
damn it we're always cosigner okay Frank
rider just got call after push the
golden buddy to 1050 data yeah boy yeah
if I got that right yeah mondo TPP Tommy
got Mangano phony don't enjoy hygiene
hotel okay to kick in
Cynthia magically point you I want you
fuck you don't get this one I will punch
you what I will punch neither we know
punching a wall punch fridges spinner
eyes okay I will punch you
I think it was trying I will cry obviou
yeah panic if you need to cook it for
number what is a shit or spirit Gangu la
color and a panic if you need to cook a
rhythm to it number t to purple stay
okay where are we in the world where are
we okay where are we feel a shot-up got
lost
i'm i we took the wrong turn wrong bus
and now we're here how do we get here
somewhere
a bus that's a clue good go be level
slow-cooked
keep it either hit roll I will go in
I heard Oh which one is it
well I knew today all right you get
three you get three frigate spins 3y 3
could you tell that that's how many you
go wrong right all right um can you pass
me the green one
now that's a green one a little green
screen away right actually that might be
cool
giving robot let's go some weight to it
yeah go down yeah
nice okay yeah all right try this one
sure oh yeah this is like a very this is
very light I think oh my all my years of
prison spinning this is definitely not a
good weight to it yeah all your years
all my many years of experience that
were talking camping around 24 minutes
oh that's damn dude
24 minutes is almost as long as this
recording yeah that's incredible
okay okay are you ready yeah where do
you want to be pictured spun on the butt
I'm not doing that I'm not I didn't say
the bike you're presenting your but to
me it's very obvious what you're
implying you got a problem with that how
do you know I know everything about your
sign boy objects why do you wanna be
finished on this not again get you the
cheek yes seriously okay don't make me
blind I will try not to you bros out
that gray
he died he died everybody beauty by
Beauty dies